so what is a recession and how does it  affect you a recession is the gross  domestic product is the total of all  goods and services in america  when it recedes when it gets smaller two  consecutive quarters  that is the definition  of a recession it means the economy is  not grown it has shrunk for two  consecutive quarters we will be in a  recession we'll know in july we will be  there we will be okay so how does that  affect everyone the job career market is  like kind of number one the thing that  it affects it's a weird weird world out  there we have a shortage of labor right  now so it's not affecting the job market  negatively yet but when businesses can't  hire because they're not growing  eventually it'll affect labor  financially it'll affect the employment  market that's probably the biggest thing  with a recession absolutely okay there  you go you heard it right from him